you don't keep track of my career but
i watch yours
is there anybody i know that cms always
likes to start is there anybody that
would like to start besides cms not that
you can't start you may start
you want to you want to jump up and work
felix okay let's do it
yeah let's do it
okay
so for your edification uh david and
karen what we do first
uh we we tape all our memorized scenes
from last week
all we've done is uh
we
read through them last week and sort of
chatted about them a little bit take a
look at uh
i'm not a believer in method or any of
that stuff the process we use on one
degree of separation from samford
meisner although we do not do repetition
exercises here
what we do however is uh improvisation
cold reading which i like to call sight
reading like in music
and we work consistently on storytelling
working moment by moment and impulse by
impulse
and that's what these guys do
so the first thing we do is tape the
scenes that we sort of read through last
week
and then we'll uh take a quick break
potty break water break coffee break
candy break
and then
we will do cold reads for next week so
that sort of brings you up to speed
keep your paper still people
please maybe he's good
just start to see i do
we're rolling do we have speed
hello howard
hello peter
i was just passing by and thought i'd
drop in
you know i haven't seen you in such a
long time
did you know that guy frank kah made me
his partner last week
no
you know you don't keep track of my
career but
i watch yours
yeah it's called frank and keating now
and i guess i don't have to tell you
that guy friend khan's the leading
architect in the country right now
no you don't have to tell me that yeah
remember how i told you once that i'd
rise
are you uh
are you waiting for something howard
you were telling me about guy frank cohn
right i was just telling you about
something i had once predicted
you know i hate to see you down like
this man
you remember how we started
and
look at us now
how much more of this can you take why
did you come here peter because we're
old friends and i hate to see you beaten
oh i'm not there's no use in lying about
it you haven't had a client in a year oh
you're wrong
it's been a year and a half right and
you might have a couple hundred dollars
left and then that's it
fourteen dollars
oh and 57 cents right right and all
those bills
i mean this is an unpaid light bill
isn't it oh no no no that is a
disconnect notice oh and that
that's an eviction notice right so how
much more of that can you take
that's my concern not yours you know you
can pay me back whenever you want by the
way
you need it
peter no thank you i don't need your
help
but i want to help
look i don't give or ask for help
why don't you drop it
what the charade
or the pose or the ideals or whatever
you want to call it
you can't stand alone anymore just give
in
learn how to get along with people first
of all
and then start designing the buildings
that everyone else does and you will be
rich
you will be successful you will be
affluent you'll
you'll finally be one of
us is that what's bothering you
oh that i want to stand alone
is that it
i don't know
look it's getting late go home peter you
lost your watch howard i hocked it good
night
good luck
and cut
all right how'd that feel pretty good
felt good should have felt good yeah it
was pretty strong he's very pretty
strong
well you know
here's the deal acting is a team sport
if you don't want to be an active member
of a team sport don't be an actor you
don't act alone even someone doing a
one-person show
doesn't act alone they have a crew they
have a sound booth they have camera
people it
you don't do it alone
so if you're concerned about your lines
and your memorization which as we get
older does happen
then you depend on your partner to help
you in the event that something goes
awry
okay
and it will so don't think it won't
because it will
you know i've worked with actors making
a half a million dollars a week that
couldn't remember their lines
they were still making a half a million
dollars a week
you know okay so what
you know i could tell you a long story
about pernell roberts and i guess
starring on a very very large major show
and both of us seasoned actors wanted to
kill the two young actors we were
working with because they kept screwing
around and horsing around
and he was a fire chief and i was a fire
captain and we kept burning down
buildings
it was not an easy [ __ ] there were there
were three crews you were literally
burning literally yeah literally burning
down buildings i thought it was a
metaphor no no no no no
it was a actual
situation
yeah so okay i like uh
go in there
be a little more
intrusive at the very beginning
you want to utz him a little bit you're
not there to help him
and at the beginning of the scene this
time it sounded as though you're really
there to help but you're not you're
there to gloat
you're there to stick it to him you're
there to put that little final last
pin in the voodoo doll
whatever
and
you just don't want to deal with him you
don't give a [ __ ] about him
you know why
i should have just slammed the door in
his face yeah well and in actuality
maybe you would have done that in real
life
but he sort of barges in you don't
really have a choice
you know and this is the sequence that
was written by the writer
so you have to do it whether you want to
or not
it's not real life no it's not it's not
real life and it's not life imitating
art or art imitating life
you know france waterfro said it the
best filmmaking is capturing life at 24
frames a second
that's what filmmaking is and it's our
job to be as realistic and honest and
open
and willing to be those things
for people to enjoy what we do
that's our job your job isn't your
objective or your motivation or any of
that crap i'll tell you what your
objective is your objective is to get
the job your motivations to get paid
those the check clears yeah yeah and
hope to check no you stay clear
you might have to fight for it sometimes
but they normally clear let's do this
again
be a little more standoffish at the
beginning you you were sort of
i don't know
not sure whether you were happy to see
him not happy to see him so let's be a
little more definitive about that
something obviously it doesn't matter
what it was
because you know the old david mamet
story i tell with the executive producer
calling him and saying well how long was
the guy in germany and david memphis
says how the hell should i know i don't
know we said you wrote the script yeah
but he could have been there five
minutes five years five days i don't
know doesn't matter it's not part of the
story he just was in germany who cares
so
we don't know what transpired between
these two people
but it's important for you
to have an instantaneous response to how
he comes into the sequence
okay got it okay cool we're ready in the
booth am i good still chill
yeah both of you both here's still good
all right
hello howard
hello peter i was just passing by and
thought i'd drop in
you know i haven't seen you in like
forever
did you know that guy friend khan made
me his partner last week
no
yeah
yeah you know
you don't keep track of my career but
i watch yours yeah it's called frank
khan keating now and i guess i don't
have to tell you that guy frank cause
the leading architect in the country
right now no you don't have to tell me
remember how i told you once that i'd
rise remember how i told you that
are you waiting for something howard
you're telling me about guy frank right
yeah i was just telling you about what i
once predicted
you know
i hate to see you down like this man
you know
you remember how we started
and look at us now
haven't you had enough
why did you come here peter because
we're old friends and i hate to see you
beaten
i'm not
well there's no use in lying about it i
mean you haven't had a client in a year
you're wrong
it's been a year and a half right you
might have a couple hundred dollars left
and then that's it
oh let's see um yeah
that's
14 and uh
57 cents oh it's impressive you think
that's enough to pay off all the bills
i mean this is a this is an unpaid light
bill isn't it no that's a disconnect
notice
and that's an eviction notice
how much more of that can you take
what's the reason you came here peter
why are you here
well
you know i want to help
and
you've given me a couple indications
here that that probably be the best
thing to do but
no thanks no thanks peter i don't want
your help thank you you sure
yeah i don't give or ask for help peter
okay
when are you gonna drop it
what
this
this
the charade or the pose
or the ideals
look
you can't stand alone anymore
just give in
learn how to get along with people first
of all
because that's always been a weak point
of yours and once you learn how to do
that
start designing the buildings that
everyone else designs and then you will
finally be rich
you'll be affluent you'll be respected
and you'll finally be one of us
i see so that's what's bothering you
right now is
that i want to stand alone
is that it
you know
howard
i don't know
yeah peter
you don't it's late go home
oh right have you lost your watch howard
i hocked it good night
good luck
see ya
bye
and cut there we go
there we go nice nice nice so here's the
thing i say it all the time don't get
sick of it but the only way that the
audience can be interested
is if you are interesting
sharing form we've got to be interested
in what we're watching otherwise we go
pee-pee or go get a coke or go get a big
bucket of popcorn or not off in the
theater exactly right good work the
changes are very good very specific all
very natural all very here's the thing
active listening active listening i i
get right before covet some of you know
i got to spend a whole evening with
morgan freeman it's one of the things we
talked about the most where was i
you weren't invited
anyway
we talked about active listening he said
that's the most important thing he ever
learned from any of the stars he was
ever fortunate enough to work with is to
listen and i was watching what was i
watching oh i started watching don't ask
me why because i'm not a big
fan but i started watching on
prime right
and there's a scene but he's talking
he's going through this wonderful
monologue and they cut to
and he's not listening
and because of the way we work
i knew he wasn't listening so with a
couple of people i was sitting and
watching with i said what do you
see here what's not right well he's not
listening
he was pretending to listen
but he wasn't listening
what you can tell
and when it was time for his lying
they cut to him and he had been thinking
about his line the whole time
and it was a parent that's what he was
doing now maybe the average joe schmoe
they may or may not see that
but you guys certainly would have
and the people i was sitting with are
not one's a writer and one's a
sales marketing person
they're not aware of that
but they sensed it because he wasn't
listening
so your listening skills guys the more
you do this
are getting better and better and better
and better and i say this all the time
ad nauseam i realize but the only way
the uncomfortable becomes comfortable is
by doing the uncomfortable it's the only
way the reason benji is a totally
different person now than he was two and
a half years ago
well it's true
it's true well
it's true because he's just a totally
different person and
he's a star he's going to have a hard
time hearing that
well and it's exemplified in his work
it's
you get the [ __ ] out of the way get
yourself out of the way and all of a
sudden things open up for you you know
so good
good work thank you good good work thank
you guys okay genie i know you i'm gonna
have you work twice so you want to go
ahead and work with adam